hello and welcome to do claim my Teochew
so get the car Oh two nights yeah here
you find this best job not a real I
don't know whether all that well I think
this is correct this is not the most
critical variation if I'm not mistaken
but I'm not sure that I know what
correcting it is okay I think it
definitely okay but probably there is
something better
we'll see this looks a lot like a French
defense
yeah I wonder if rook h4 is a decent
move or if this is just too fancy I can
also take Queen e2 and this is a simple
solution let's do it kara f2 I mean one
thing we know like it's not going to
Castle short in this position a for stop
this may be d4 is a smooth okay so he is
canceling long yeah here before is the
is the standard idea but okay I have to
first problem well I can also just do I
want to develop first Bishop f4 and that
looks very healthy yeah just developed
first like h6 I have G 45 Bishop d3 that
should also be strategically nice I
don't need to necessarily castle
so what and play like before and yeah
play out so aggressively it should not
be a necessity here okay so what's going
on here if I take it I don't have a
clear continuation but I can I can do
this first and then see what he is up to
Peaks Knight takes Knight takes Queen
takes as good yeah this is just going
into night age for directly which is
maybe not an issue admittedly
if I take it he's going to do what with
the pawn I can also just castle so I
mean I'm pretty quick there with before
I wonder h5 maybe than g5 935 probably
have to take on f6 unsure him
[Music]
yeah so before takes on G form
takes on c5 come on let's be quick
I wonder if he takes it on G 465 icons
just comes back okay here
simple b5 is going to be an idea or
taking I mean taking his quicker
let's do this
what
that's playable well that's shocking
really why King da door what's that what
what's the idea I'm not I'm completely
stunned here King d8 said working I
would be pretty shocking maybe it does
yeah that's the idea
okay so whoa what's going on here check
you should see a tithe Inc I have to
check here first and then see what's
going on Bishop f6 okay I can check here
King e7 that's not so great
yeah I don't want to play Queen 21 okay
huh weird
so d4 he has to play and the wise Bishop
c7
so he gives up the Queen okay Jay
checking is under fending f2 probably
not jealous maybe just try to be very
quick iam over the tempo
and then he's got the morning
Queen Bishop e6 we should be six simply
yeah my idea was to take g7 but that's
it's also controversial probably cannot
remove the pieces here well check yet
like him keep everything covered
we should maybe threaten a book c7 here
that would clarify matters if I can take
it
how do I play this deform doesn't do
that takes Queen d5 wind stuff
they are both hanging and drew gauge 6s
g8 hanging so I think J I think I'm
getting there g3
let's go a g3 check but with rooks I'm
defender I don't plan if you can gently
both Jeff Jeff black resilience
I was I was tricky oh it's um somehow
tricky even after the win looked like it
was in the back okay so I have not I
don't really know that looks very normal
takes takes yeah well before it's maybe
a threat okay so I went a for myself I'm
not sure about this now instead of this
just canceling probably also was a good
idea completely ignoring everything
there I mean I still have this before
thing for me it wasn't necessary to to
play this Bishop f4 ng form you know the
the engine doesn't like it all that much
no before hmm
yeah that gets it such a to total mess
now he went back but the set should be
good after b5 so after this the engine
wants to kunai destroy us it was one
thing I was thinking I can also take but
this this doesn't feel good yeah
that's not great
okay what he took you go when you back I
went this yeah that looks really really
bad but it did not lose straight away at
least not with my play yeah so this this
and Bishop f5 is the engines more okay
so takes roopd one that's wrong it's
definitely strong okay so this is Queen
d6 is better and now now I'm winning
again yeah deform Queen e5 looks
terrible now I'm on the dark squares
really
that's a +5 okay okay yeah I was willing
a screen but things are not that easy b6
is just trying to play for over Tempe
here the d6 pawn is always going to be
difficult to play against but the engine
agrees with us yeah okay here it's a
draw but you know this is so so
difficult
rook g5 and this wasn't that good Queen
f3 not this one but this is also good
bishop c6 Wow
what about my move is also good that's
that's cool I'm happy with that move
that that look good you look very
forcing Jamie my rook c5 was good okay
but my idea was exactly the game that
after g3 if he takes it that this should
probably be stuff he can probably avoid
losing the rook immediately yeah no I
can take this check so it's very
comfortable probably probably winning
forward I mean the two rooks are always
difficult to play
yes but it should be okay okay guys
thanks for watching